A century ago there were an estimated 100,000
tigers in the wild.
Today there are only 3,200 tigers left in
the entire world.
If cats don't encounter people by the time
they're 10 weeks old, they will always be
scared of them.
There are more statues of lions in the world
than there are real lions.
The first ever product to have a barcode was
a pack of Wrigley's gum.
5% of cats are allergic to humans.
Qatar is the only country that begins with
a Q and Iraq is the only country that ends
with one.
Reed Hastings was inspired to start Netflix
after racking up a $40 late fee on a VHS copy
of Apollo 13.
Due to precipitation, for a few weeks every
year, K2 is taller than Mt.
Everest.
The Burmese sneezing monkey sneezes uncontrollably
whenever it rains.
Charles Darwin let his children use the original
manuscript of On the Origin of Species as
drawing paper.
If we had the same mortality rate now as in
1900, more than half the people in the world
today would not be alive.
In Utah, it is illegal to swear in front of
a dead person.
Olympic medal-winners live almost three years
longer than the rest of us.
Michael Phelps has won more Olympic golds
than India, Nigeria, North Korea, Portugal,
Taiwan and Thailand combined.
Camel urine is as thick as syrup.
The soil in your back garden is two million
years old.